we can finally say that scream will
forever be csgo's one tap God really
struggle what with CSG go coming to an
end all of the stats from professional
play have now been solidified this of
course includes scream's insane headshot
percentage of
68.1% quite a big tell when they're call
me oh my God scream over scream CS
career he became known for one thing and
one thing only tapping heads and thanks
to his propensity for popping melons
scream racked up and impressive headshot
rating that set himself apart from his
contemporaries two
more wo scream might not have a cabinet
filled with trophies but holding on to
that statline despite not having played
professionally since 2019 proves just
how skilled he was and for that he'll be
a CS Legend forever